hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be like my wrap-up for Luke Cage
season 1 as well as season 2 defenders
Iron Fist Heroes for Hire stuff so just
careful for spoilers from Luke Cage
season 1 so overall I think everybody's
in agreement that Luke Cage was an
amazing series but you know where I
think people start to depart we're like
opinions start to separate is where it
fits in the pantheon of Marvel's Netflix
series so I still think that daredevil
season 2 is probably the most fun Marvel
series so far I'm hoping that iron fist
knocks that off its pedestal because the
tone of iron fist is supposed to be so
fun like the way they've been pitching
it but Jessica Jones is like this deeply
psychological story that I feel like was
the best storytelling so far but there
wasn't so much action in it so I feel
like the big daredevil fans didn't like
it quite as much Luke Cage had a little
more action like there were definitely a
lot of people that got the beatdown but
it was really light when it came to
story so I feel like all the comic book
people that watch marvel stuff because
they're doing the comic book characters
like hey we're doing this character that
you read about that's so awesome we're
disappointed when it came to the story
but overall I feel like Luke Cage was a
big success there haven't been any big
series like this besides like blade
about african-american characters that's
another thing too there's rumors about
blade stuff happening in the Marvel
Universe but I feel like Luke Cage is a
drama series like if you set the
superhero comic book stuff aside was
really awesome
it's just that it falters a little bit
when you try to fit it inside this comic
book universe because you have to
remember that their comic book
characters they wouldn't be doing these
series if they didn't want to do comic
book characters if they wanted to do a
drama series that had nothing to do with
the comics they would just use different
names they wouldn't call it Luke Cage
but overall I felt like it was six
episodes of really solid story stretched
out into 13 hours of content so that's
why it felt kind of sluggish at the
beginning and it almost felt like his
character had backtracked like they were
redoing some of his character arc from
Jessica Jones so that's why I think a
lot of people were confused where this
took place in the timeline because the
way Luke Cage was acting in the first
couple of episodes was exactly the way
he was at
at the beginning of Jessica Jones so I
don't know if that was a conscious
choice on the part of the showrunner of
Luke Cage but they all talked to each
other like all the Netflix show runners
talk to each other so they know what
each of their characters is doing so I
was a little disappointed in them
rehashing a lot of his character arc him
hiding out he was hiding out in Jessica
Jones the end of that should have
synched up with say like the second or
third episode of Luke Cage and then you
really don't get into an actual plot
driven story until striker appears which
is around Episode six so I actually feel
like they should have started that
striker encounter with the street fight
they had at the very end of the series
it almost felt anticlimactic the way it
went down it felt like a really good
fight but the conclusions he comes to
were so simple that it's almost like you
could have done that in Episode six and
then done something way more plot driven
like is there a wealthy person say like
in the Iron Fist universe that's
supplying striker with those hammer
weapons because it doesn't sound like
he's getting them straight from Hammer
tech and for those that are wondering
Justin Hammer is still in prison but his
company like a lot of big Marvel
companies are so big and makes so much
money that they continue on even when
they're figureheads die or get set in
prison they said during iron fist
they're going to take a hard look they
called it a hard look quote-unquote at
the top 1% or the top 1% of the top 1%
so like the wealthiest of the wealthy
you're talking like how Tony Stark rich
people in their actions Big Pharma big
corporations influence what's happening
at street level so like you think about
that company and Jessica Jones that they
were all investigating where she got her
powers from the ones that were
experimenting on kilgrave there let you
know think of them as like a big
faceless evil corporation they're gonna
take a harder look at stuff like that
during the Iron Fist series my
understanding though is the reason why
Luke Cage was so self-contained and felt
so small and was probably kind of thin
on the story is is because they wanted
you know open to closed just to focus on
that character inside the Harlem
community so they did an amazing job of
that the Harlem that they presented in
the series was
formed all the characters had great
development I just feel like they could
have done the exact same thing though in
like half the number of episodes so you
get to spend more time doing more plot
driven stuff but I still love the music
I know a lot of people complain that
they use Gang Starr songs as the titles
of each of the episodes but did not
notice any actual Gang Starr songs used
in the episodes so it's like why would
you make them the titles if you weren't
gonna use those songs in the episodes it
almost doesn't make sense so they're
just like a lot of little things they
kind of hamper Luke Cage so I feel like
season two now that they've established
these characters they can actually have
some fun and do an actual plot driven
story but just going down the list like
my favorite actors like all of them had
great performances but some of them
which is way above and beyond
so of course alfre woodard was amazing
as Mariah Mike Colter is an amazing Luke
Cage but I feel like Shades was amazing
as well as striker
even though striker got a little bit
silly late in his story he came on so
strong so I'll talk about the ending in
a second too but I feel like striker
will come back next season he'll be a
lot more fun cottonmouth may he rest in
peace also an amazing performance as
well as pops pops was a lot of fun I was
disappointed that they didn't let
striker kill pops because strikers whole
thing is that he didn't get the love
from his father that he felt like Luke
Cage was stealing in pops was kind of
like a surrogate father to Luke Cage so
I feel like it would have been better if
striker had killed pops but that was
just one of like the plotting problems
and like the way they told the story
across the season like they didn't want
to do striker till after they had done
the cottonmouth arc so you kind of see
how they differentiate this season you
have the first half of the season which
is like the fall of cottonmouth then you
have the rise and fall of striker in the
back half so hopefully next season Luke
Cage won't drag his feet so much but
just to talk about the ending so we saw
striker with the doctor that helped give
Luke Cage his powers although
technically it was an accident
he's probably going to find that because
Luke Cage has a special DNA that enabled
him to survive that treatment in striker
is his brother striker will also be able
to survive that treatment so when
striker comes back he'll be twice as
powerful twice as evil without the need
for all the tech but he
did actually get to his comic book
costume at the end I like the way they
did that like they had a little bit of
fun joking with luke cage's comic book
costume I look ridiculous but they had
strike her in his Diamondback comic book
costume by the end - just like the way
that Hammer tech suit looked I felt like
the biggest collective WCF everyone had
at the end though was when Luke age got
arrested by the FBI
we're like he defeats Stryker everybody
sees it happen they know that he is not
the villain but still like the FBI just
kind of comes in in the last two minutes
of the episode and like hey we're taking
you away like Claire temple said she
knows a good lawyer
so daredevil is gonna be the one to get
him out of prison clear his name I hope
that they don't sideline the beginning
of defenders dealing with that because
that would be like the exact same thing
that happened at the beginning of Luke
Cage after Jessica Jones but the easter
egg at the end like the tease for iron
fist was colleen wings martial arts
academy the Claire temple like you know
rips the little tab off so at New York
Comic Con rosario dawson was like oh
hell yeah yeah like Claire temple is
gonna get to kick a lot more ass during
the Iron Fist series but for those of
you asking if they're gonna do a Heroes
for Hire series I don't think they're
actually gonna do that they'll have
Heroes for Hire stuff happening but
they're not gonna call it Heroes for
Hire
they'll just call it Luke Cage season
two in Iron Fist season two there are so
few series centered around
african-american characters in the way
Luke ages they don't want to diminish
that by mixing it with another show so
what they'll do is is they'll just have
a bunch of crossovers with Iron Fist
characters and other Netflix characters
really in the way we saw crossovers
during daredevil season two like
Punisher Elektra they were a bunch of
new characters during daredevil season
two so expect stuff like that to be
happening during Luke Cage season two
and Iron Fist season two so they haven't
really confirmed anything but like my
thought is is that we'll see at least
five seasons of each of the Netflix
series unless something big changes like
the actors leave or something happens
behind the scenes so money is no object
when it comes to making these it's
really just a matter of the actors
wanting to keep doing them and they all
seem really jazzed up about their
characters but short term just plan on
like two to three
phases of defenders team ups so we'll
have like a bunch of seasons of each of
the individual shows and then at least a
couple big defenders team ups I don't
think it's gonna be an annual thing but
it might be like every two years but
Netflix will probably say more about
that when defenders actually does drop
and they did say that they're starting
to shoot that at the beginning of
November
like they just finished iron fist there
was a video all about that so I'll link
that at the end of this but let me know
what did you guys think about the Luke
Cage series as a whole and what do you
want them to do with season 2 I know
everybody wants Iron Fist Heroes for
Hire they're like please just give us a
thing just let him have all the funds
there were some more comic-book
characters in there just get really
weird with it but heads up tonight new
episode of the flash is posting be sure
to subscribe to get that Jesse quick is
debuting as the next female speedster so
it's gonna be crazy
changing the outro just a little bit so
why you guys waiting for that next video
you can click up top for the Iron Fist
trailer and you can click down here for
all my other defenders videos thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight